there is one field we desperately
need groundbreaking breakthrough
innovation and that's the necessary
shift towards a sustainable
economy and this is the field of
scientist emily shuckburgh the director
of cambridge zero the university of
cambridge
climates initiative and we are very glad
that she is contributing to the berlin
science week and i have the chance to
talk to her now i'm virtually connected
to her and talk to her about her vision
of zero carbon futures thank you for
joining us emily it's a pleasure to have
you with us
oh it's a pleasure as well um the
climate crisis
is um next to covet 19 the most
discussed topic of our time
what aspects of this problem would you
wish should get more
coverage well i spent much my career
working as a polar scientist and i
would say that having wider
understanding of the scale of the
changes that we're seeing today in the
polar regions
would be really welcome the
in the arctic the scale of sea ice
retreat is is
almost unimaginable um at the end of the
melt season we're seeing
a loss of sea ice compared to 40 years
ago that's equivalent to the area of
uh of the united kingdom france spain
germany poland all put together in the
antarctic the vast
west antarctic ice sheet is melting and
we are concerned
that indeed it might be an irreversible
retreat and if
this ice sheets over greenland and west
antarctica did indeed collapse that
would eventually lead to many meters of
sea level rise
well there are many global very complex
problems
which have to be solved in this context
how is your initiative going about
fostering the level of international
cooperation
we're looking very much across all
different dimensions of what a
university
can be delivering and as you say looking
very much in the context of
international cooperation around that
so interco international cooperation
around the science that's required to
drive the innovations that will lead us
to a
zero carbon walls but also corporation
around the education
and um all the uh engagements beyond
um the university itself with business
and policy makers
uh okay what would you say are the top
three
most important scientific advancements
we have to get done
in order to to achieve your goals
so there are many different areas where
there's actually currently today
exciting science on being undertaken to
help drive
drivers towards a zero carbon future but
if i was to pick three areas
the first would be in the area of energy
technologies particularly
battery storage technologies we know
that so much of our world is going to be
transitioned to an electric world
and having that battery storage is
critically important to underpin that
the second area that i would point to is
transport it's another major part of our
emissions
we know that our ground transport our
cars are
very rapidly moving towards
electrification
but aviation is a is a key part of our
transport system
and looking to see how we can deliver
zero carbon aviation
into the future is a is a is a critical
research challenge
at the moment and then the final area
that i would point to is greenhouse gas
removal
um if we are to address climate change
we're going to need to find
ways of actively removing greenhouse
gases from the atmosphere either by
technological means
or by natural means enhancing nature in
a way that can
help the climate problem but if we're
going to do that we need to ensure that
at the same time
it's also helping the biodiversity
crisis that we're also experiencing at
the moment
well we're looking forward to meet you
again during the
session at the summit here thank you so
much for sharing your insights emily
schachberg thanks a lot for this talk
thank you